the science of kovid collapsing in real
time is at least sometimes amusing it's
pretty annoying that we shut down
society for two years and upended
people's lives and took away our rights
and destroyed the economy and on and on
and on that's that's annoying i don't
mean to downplay that but there is
something funny about the people who
scream until they're red in the face
blue in the face they say you have to
get your 17th booster shot and wear 57
masks wherever you go oh yeah i got
kovid for the fifth time this year
uh wait i i guess your strategy's not
working they say no no thank goodness i
got my my
75th booster otherwise it would have
been much worse
which they say based on
nothing at all the people who
told us made a declarative statement
about what the vaccines would do that
they would stop you from catching and
spreading the virus then that was
completely false they say no but believe
us on this hypothetical because we would
be totally right there so there was
something somewhat amusing about that
when the science collapse around
an issue like transgenderism it's
considerably less amusing because on the
issue of transgenderism right now
specifically transiting the kids you
have these adults some of whom are just
psychos and some of whom are just
ignorant
they are for whatever reason malice or
stupidity
really really messing up really little
kids lives and giving them osteoporosis
at a young age and sterilizing them and
conducting
some of the most heinous medical
experiments that have ever been
conducted on some of the most vulnerable
people that you possibly can and so
that's
that's not so funny okay and they're
doing it based on the science they're
doing it based on this one claim i
promise you you've heard it which is
that
if if we don't trans the kids if we
don't put kids on puberty blockers and
pump them full of cross-sex hormones and
sterilize them and completely transform
their bodies
they'll kill themselves if you don't
indulge transgender ideology you're
you're just
leading your kid by the hand to go
commit suicide what would you rather
have a a dead daughter or a living son
that's the kind of stuff that they say
it's not just the libs who say it or
it's
not just the nominally liberal
institutions it's even fox news we
played this clip yesterday fox news the
the
purportedly conservative cable news
channel came out and used these exact
kinds of lines
there was a father who was sitting
across the table he says you have no
idea how lucky you are to be here which
kind of took me back i didn't at that
point consider myself lucky to be there
and he said you know our our child had
displayed
this gender dysphoria or this gender
misalignment at at the same age that
rylan has
and
we didn't listen and we pushed back that
pushback led that child to turn to
self-harm as a teenager which 60 percent
of trans and non-binary kids engage in
according to the trevor project more
than 50 percent consider suicide that
for me was the turning point i didn't
want to see rylan to go through that i'd
rather have a living son than a dead
daughter i guarantee that if we had
pushed back and
done what a lot of parents do
i don't think that we would have
either one of the kids that you see
before you here today
there it is all the hits i'd rather have
a living son than a dead daughter what
would you what you want your kid to die
i've got statistics i've got the science
from the trevor project a radical lgbt
organization so what are you going to do
and what they're offering you here
is a kind of faustian bargain they're
offering you here a little bit of a deal
with the devil
which is they're saying look
even if you don't believe that the
little girl is actually a little boy
you should lie
you should tell a lie you should do
something that is intrinsically dis
immoral
and you should do it for a good end
because if you don't lie
and if we as a society don't all lie
and pretend that the little boys are
little girls and vice versa
then they're all going to kill
themselves so if you want the good end
you need to commit this immoral act
and
they present this scientific evidence
so-called
to say but you will get the good you
will get the good end the child will not
commit suicide if you lie and mutilate
his or her genitals and put them on
cross-sex hormones
then the kid won't kill him or herself
the thing about faustian bargains
the thing about deals with the devil
is they don't work
they don't they something always goes
wrong
and we're seeing it go wrong right here
in the science it turns out that all
that science all those fancy numbers and
statistics about how if you
mutilate your kids genitals then they
won't commit suicide it's just fake it's
just made up like so much of the
politicized science that we've heard
about in recent years this one is just
fake too at least that's what
the more credible reputable science says
there's a very important new study out
of the heritage foundation this is by
j.p greene
shows that
easing access to puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones has not only not
has only not decreased
youth suicide rates
it's actually increased youth suicide
rates
this is contrary to the claims of the
trevor project and the biden
administration and fox freaking news for
goodness sakes it's contrary to this
prior flawed research that the liberal
establishment is touting right now
so you're
the way i mean the paper is complicated
you can go read it over the heritage
foundation but the broad strokes of it
is
puberty blockers are introduced around
2010.
starting around 2015 they really start
to accelerate
you can check this by looking at
internet trend data google trend data
searches for these kinds of terms
puberty blockers transgender dysphoria
gender identity disorder and so what
jp green did here is he compared the
youth suicide rates in states where it
is easier for minors to get the puberty
blockers to states where it is harder
for minors to get the puberty blockers
after 2010 after the introduction of all
this stuff youth suicide rates increase
in states where it is easier for minors
to access the puberty blockers and the
hormones relative to the states where it
was harder so they're they're
controlling for differences within the
states they're just looking at the time
difference they're just looking and and
they're specifically looking at this
group of young people this is really
important
by 2020 there were more than 1.6 more
suicides per 100 000 young people in the
states that had the easier access and
because the state average is 11.1 this
means that the youth suicide rate
increased by 14
so you're so you're looking
you see a dramatic increase in suicide
rates where the puberty blockers and the
hormones are more easily accessible when
they become widely available among
specifically those who would be affected
this shows strong evidence that the the
claims about transiting the kids that
the libs have been making are completely
false so you think you're going to make
this deal with the devil and you say
look i know i just know intrinsically
that there is something wrong about
chopping up my kids genitals and putting
them on cross-sex hormones and
sterilizing them but i just feel so
emotionally
manipulated here and i just i i don't
have the data and i don't have the
science and i know it's wrong in my gut
but i don't have it and so you go ahead
and do it and what are you doing not
only are you not decreasing the risk to
your kid you're massively increasing the
risk to your kid that the simple
takeaway is you cannot believe the
extraordinarily politicized signs if
justin trudeau gets kovid for the second
time this year shot up 57 times
with with the vaccines and the boosters
and whatever else he can get
if if that kind of science which we've
been told
ad nauseam for the past year
is not reliable certainly this kind of
radical medical experimentation on kids
is not reliable i'm glad you like that
clip now
you got a ring
bing bam wada wada ding dong ring that
bell and subscribe get the notifications
to the michael knowles show head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play myspace xanga aol instant messenger
the fax machine wherever you get your
audio podcasts subscribe to the michael
knoll show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you